two days before the UK exits the
European Union on the 31st of January
Parliament will vote on the withdrawal
agreement in a recent resolution mep
sworn they could withhold their consent
if concerns about citizens rights were
not addressed by the UK government on
average women in the EU earn 16% less
per hour than men Parliament has
consistently called for more action to
narrow the gap and will vote on the
steps that must be taken to end this
injustice
it's estimated that old charges generate
more than 51,000 tons of electronic
waste every year
MEP s will vote on a text calling for a
common charger to fit all mobile phones
tablets eBook readers and other portable
devices Parliament will mark the 75th
anniversary of the liberation of the
Auschwitz concentration camp with a
ceremony in memory of all the victims of
the Holocaust during the second world
war more than 6 million European Jews
Roma and other persecuted groups were
murdered by the Nazi regime thousands of
people have been arrested and dozens
killed in protests since the Indian
government introduced a controversial
citizenship law it excludes Muslims
fleeing religious persecution from
eligibility to seek Indian nationality
MEP s will vote on a resolution
condemning the legislation